[Music]
and radiation cover-up news oh don't
tell me Japan got some new [ __ ]
submitted by broom broom tourists have
been exposed to radiation for years at a
Grand Canyon Museum I took tanka degrees
we didn't go to the museum but no
museums are boring really I think they
have uranium the rhenium right uranium
great [ __ ] uranium why would they
have your ring oh I thought it was on
display somewhere still we had five
gallon container or five gallon
containers are filled with uranium just
in case you've just had it there what
you just had it there just to be clear
like I haven't found a reason as to why
like I feel like the government was like
hey we need a place the whole uranium
just for a minute and the museum like Oh
rocks that I don't know how they
obtained or how do you would it what are
they what is uranium used for or what
nuclear shoot a nuclear oh they still
use up yeah that's when it causes like
the reaction of not like nuclear reactor
you need uranium for nuclear power
plants okay so from 2002 June 18 2008
teen holy [ __ ] you went to this
particular build you guys post already
do that expose to a shit-ton irradiation
a [ __ ] ton yeah real it's about 400
times for adults like the the
recommended oh and four thousand times
for children and they were saying that
they would have tours here because it
was stored right next to this Texan
derby case and they would have children
go and look at it and they'd have these
whole like 30 minute presentations in
that room everybody sit on the [ __ ]
uranium drums it was this building
building to see okay I want to go in nad
just do they just forget and when no one
was experiencing side effects for 18
like did anyone work long enough to well
that's the beauty about tourism right
you have people from all over the world
coming in and in the
go back to the where they came from
well one of the workers turned into a
giant spider and either when you called
away they're already in the southwest
this was the the case the Texas memory
case and these gallon container five
gallon containers who were here they
were just kept in these little things
oh just [ __ ] Homer buckets from Home
Depot Jesus and then oh Sh I believe
ocean they came because that's not
workers [ __ ] safety people OSHA safety
hazard yeah I remember in our warehouse
were like oh she's here and we have
[ __ ] do all this [ __ ] I used to work
in a warehouse I mean yeah fire
extinguishers [ __ ] so distract the OSHA
man with like a [ __ ] everyone act
like you're really happy with your job
they're looking for problems and [ __ ] oh
the [ __ ] ladders too close oh [ __ ]
was he writing yeah so they're saying
that this uranium threat was discovered
in March of 2018 by the teenage son of a
park employee who so happens to be a
Geiger counter enthusiast which is like
the machine that measures radiation god
for that nurse be immediately removed or
move the bucket to another location in
the building
oh dude that [ __ ] got that like
prong and he's like you know how it
makes that radiate radiation no he's
like like going crazy
he's like dad 17 not eight and they put
it in the back and they put in a plastic
Ralph's bag and took you to the basement
yeah there's a lot of radiation here
this man named Elston he's the safety
health and wellness manager he was doing
an audit and then that's when one of the
employees mentioned this he was like
what like we should do something about
this we mention the uranium
right why do they have uranium again
just for display I don't I don't know
why it's not even buckets one of the
buckets were so full - Quinn really
lived in you enclose Oh
that much uranium no dude like did they
think it was a special moon rock or some
[ __ ] what are the side effects or
something like that like answers
yeah cancer with cells like your cells
could die or they could multiply like
Perloff cancer get superpowers they're
all x-men there now yeah oh you went to
the museum
no I've been to the Grand Canyon those
but I was like okay I've never seen that
building before so he instantly called a
national parks specialist in Colorado
but then the specialists apparently
didn't have uranium tears filter Sun
they drove to my thing at the 17 year
old to pick up this Ludum Louboutin
Ludlum meter which also measures
radiation outputs and then they once
they got there several days later they
found or they weren't even wearing
protects Oh Lord they're in a tank top
they're purchased dishwashing and garden
gloves put suntan lotion on
they used a broken mop handle to lift
the buckets into the truck and then
that's when they took all no so they're
exposing themselves the entire stoop so
then they dumped the uranium into an old
uranium dig okay and then they brought
the bucket oh dude leave the [ __ ]
bucket are they like just not really
uneducated and I ever seen a movie whoa
I'm just assuming that they are kind of
Brenda brown brown brown brown brown
like maybe Oh what do you mean with that
just the West Virginia types you know
like inbred Ted but you don't have to be
inbred I mean there's smart inbred
people like the royal families in
Brandeis there's some West Virginians
for their dad I'm just the I'm just
thinking like dandy I'm [ __ ] around
West Virginia Jesus maybe they didn't go
to school why didn't they call it the
[ __ ] government yeah well they
obviously didn't think it was a big deal
right
they look like they're covered okay you
know that's after the fact right well I
don't know they're claiming that these
are it but um yeah
well this is why they're in Queens oh
and then
pretty much when complaints were
escalated that's when the guy a just
lazy like fine I'll do it
fine all right yeah I guess so that's
when um
this dude was fired but then he turned
to the Office of Special Counsel which
is a federal agency that protects
whistleblowers and then his termination
was stayed and yeah but apparently he
has a new job oh gosh you know Park
Service that's so sad this does do this
I'd be pissed at how many idiots I was
working with yeah he's a military vet
and he's also certified an occupational
safety and health technician and so no
one wanted to listen to this guy I know
well well I want to know what the
reasoning was for the dumb asses it
seemed like they were just trying to
like cover this up and they also don't
really know what steps to take to cover
it up
not like now because what he ended up
doing is he sent eight a notice to
everyone pretty much telling them like
hey you have been exposed to high
amounts of radiation from this end of
this time everyone needs to know about
this because they the first people at
the higher-ups they were just we're not
letting people know I really wanna I
want a panel of all the higher up people
and everyone involved and I just want to
watch the conference yes
like how are they gonna try to lie their
asses off with this [ __ ] suit yeah
well your honor we put in at that time
we did put it in a bucket yeah - two
buckets well we put a lid on it
we had gloves on and we bought red
buckets just so that people know that
it's bad like red is bad don't worry we
got latex well it's not the non latex we
got the lady to explore yeah
how would impede the [ __ ] who's who
thought that was okay I want to hear
their no got there long who like doctor
10 years dude uranium is like super
controlled it's here right cuz people
kind of make bombs out of it and [ __ ]
and meanwhile just [ __ ] sitting in a
bucket at some public publicly
accessible place well cuz what guy was
moving all right well cuz a terrorist
was moving and he was like oh
so I got all this uranium here and you
guys have a museum
do you like education right like I don't
want it to go to waste guys you want it
bigger out of place charitable
terrorists yeah and they're like oh my
terrorist days are over you know yeah
I'm getting now yeah he's like I'm done
okay we can find a nice home for your
uranium putting on a fire sale right
yeah Wow yes I was saying that he
pressed park superintendents to take
action he submitted an inspector general
complaint he contacted the FBI damn good
for that and he also wrote to every
member of Congress know in a letter
that's when I love tattletales he's
covering his ass dude that's what he's
doing which is good but like how did he
find out yeah no it was a different
employee oh then they told him and then
when he was doing an audit that's when
he felt like month later
that's him they find out cuz if he
didn't tell those people after knowing
that [ __ ] he's bought as hell and that's
what his higher-ups are dealing with
right now
and then so now they're just saying like
you know how do we even handle this like
how do we let all these visitors that
shit's meaning [ __ ] Fukushima right
there yeah and all these like foreigners
I visit like Cuddy over was 18 years 18
years that it was sitting there I was 18
yeah it was just 10 mm from - I don't
know why I said ten oh I was going off
of your ten years building popularly
used I hope not I hope it was one of
those like off the road kind of museums
like come to the Colorado Grand Canyon
Museum and in they have like one feather
and it's like this one came off of chief
wrong it says that it's used to house
and carry perfect academia tours and
tortoises okay so all these children
approximately two to five workers were
in the building daily there were minor
aged interns were they like no wonder
I'm dating [ __ ] different genitals on
my back
like who dicks on my back now I know why
finally know approximately 800 to a
thousand visitors every year and there
were minor ages that's pretty crazy yeah
dude
the lawsuits that could come out of this
there's gonna be so many child lobsters
lawsuit lobsters lobsters kids with
Klaus he says hundred times the amount
in in like just a few seconds imagine
that we're there for like half an hour
presentation working there for you 12
hours a day and I'm working there yeah
and that in that room what the hell
what kind of superpower are they gonna
get just can't fight a party can climb
walls if you knew you could get a
superpower but you couldn't pick it
would you be down ah the possibility of
getting a superpower or getting cancer
and dying oh no all right I'll take the
suing for money
[Music]